Salut les épicurieuses et les épicurieux !
Aujourd'hui, je pense que je vais
en faire saliver plus d'une et plus d'un.
Vous êtes prêts ? Attention.
Aujourd'hui, je vous raconte l'histoire
des bonbons. Qui les a inventés ?comment on
les fabrique ? Les durs, les mous...
Comment on leur donne de la couleur
et pourquoi les bonbons on adore ça !
Qui a inventé les bonbons ? Au VIᵉ siècle
avant Jésus-Christ,
les Perses envahissent l'Inde.
Ils y découvrent un roseau qui, selon
leurs propres termes, donne du miel
sans le concours des abeilles.
Vous avez bien sûr reconnu
la canne à sucre.
Elle pousse en Inde et en Chine
depuis au moins 8000 ans.
Les habitants la mâchonnent un peu comme
on le fait avec un bâton de réglisse.
Il en sort un jus savoureux.
En Inde, ce jus est
baptisé Sarkara. Sarkara,
sucre, ça se ressemble tout ça !
Bien vu. C'est effectivement ce terme
tiré du sanskrit
qui donnera le mot sucre
dans la langue française.
Mais revenons aux Perses.
Ils rapportent la canne chez eux
et se mettent à la cultiver.
Puis les Arabes étendent sa culture
à d'autres régions méditerranéennes.
Le sucre ne débarque en Occident qu'au XIᵉ
ou XIIᵉ siècle, quand les croisés
le rapportent d'Orient.
À l'époque, on parle de sel sucré.
C'est vrai que les deux se ressemblent,
mais ils n'ont pas le même goût.
Et on le considère
d'ailleurs comme une épice.
Et comme toutes les épices,
il est vendu à prix d'or.
Du coup, sa consommation
est réservée à l'aristocratie.
On l'utilise pour préparer
des fruits confits ou des confitures.
Comme le sel, le sucre
permet de déshydrater
les fruits et donc de les conserver
car en l'absence d'eau
les bactéries ne peuvent
plus se développer.
A cette époque, il est vendu
par les apothicaires.
Aujourd'hui, on dirait pharmacien.
Car on lui attribue aussi
des vertus thérapeutiques.
Ah des bonbons pour aller mieux.
On savait vivre au
Moyen-Âge ! Au XVᵉ siècle.
un cuisinier lance
la mode des épices de chambre.
Cette friandise peut véritablement être
considérée comme l'ancêtre de nos bonbons.
On utilise du gingembre, des amandes
ou de la cannelle
que l'on fait rissoler dans du sucre
et que l'on déguste à l'issue du dîner
avant de se mettre au lit.
On pensait alors que le sucre soulageait
les douleurs de poitrine
et facilitait la digestion.
Peut-être qu'il servait aussi à masquer
le mauvais goût de certains aliments.
C'est bon, même si ça ne vaut pas
un bon bonbon.
Si vous aimez vraiment les bonbons,
c'est surtout Catherine de Médicis
qu'il faut remercier.
A l'occasion de son mariage,
l'Italienne glisse plusieurs recettes
au goût sucré dans son trousseau
et les rapporte en France.
Selon certaines sources,
l'un de ses confiseurs,
un certain Jean Pastilla, aurait répandu
la mode des pastilles à base de gomme
arabique et de sirop de sucre.
Jean, pastilla, pastilles,
ça ne s'invente pas.
Et pourtant, le nom du confiseur n'a
rien à voir avec le nom du membre.
Au XVIIIᵉ siècle,
les premières confiseries
ouvrent leurs portes à Paris.
La bourgeoisie se précipite
devant les gommes, les pastilles aux
fruits, les marrons glacés, les dragées,
les fruits confits, les pralines.
Enfin ! Doucement !
Ces friandises coûtent encore bonbon.
Enfin, coûtent cher.
Tiens, d'ailleurs,
savez-vous quel est l'étymologie
du mot friandise ?
Il vient du participe présent du verbe
frire, qui signifiait
brûler d'envie, frétiller d'impatience.
Ce n'est qu'au XIXᵉ siècle,
grâce à la découverte
du sucre de betterave,
que le bonbon se démocratise.
Moins cher que le sucre de canne,
le sucre de betterave libère l'imagination
des confiseurs et conduit à l'explosion
des formes, des couleurs et des saveurs.
C'est aussi pendant cette période
de la révolution industrielle
que les techniques de fabrication
des bonbons ont le plus progressées.
Allez, direction la cuisine.
Pour fabriquer des bonbons,
on fait fondre du sucre dans de l'eau
et on élève la température.
Les molécules de saccharose qui composent
les cristaux de sucre se séparent.
Et ce n'est pas tout.
En plus du sucre et de l'eau,
on ajoute du sirop de glucose,
un liquide très visqueux obtenu à partir
d'amidon de blé ou de maïs.
Ce sirop empêche
le sucre de cristalliser trop vite.
C'est important.
Ça laisse du temps aux confiseurs
pour façonner différentes formes de
bonbons par la suite.
Ça permet aussi aux bonbons
de mieux se conserver.
Ça permet également de faire monter
la température du mélange initial.
Sans ce sirop de glucose,
le sucre brûle très rapidement.
OK pour les ingrédients !
Mais c'est quoi alors
la différence entre ça
et ça ? Eh bien, justement,
le confiseur va jouer
sur la température pour confectionner
différents types de bonbons. À 100 degrés,
on obtient un sirop
qui forme un petit filet.
On appelle cela le nappé.
Quand la température atteint 120 degrés,
ça commence vraiment
à devenir intéressant.
En effet, entre 120 et 126 degrés,
on peut fabriquer
du nougat ou de la guimauve.
Mmmh j'adore ! Entre 145 et 150 degrés,
le sirop durcit. Il devient cassant
car il a perdu beaucoup d'eau.
Tous les bonbons
dits de sucre cuits, les sucettes,
les berlingots sont fabriqués
à cette température de chauffe.
Et puis, au delà de 150 degrés,
le sucre brunit et on obtient du caramel.
En France, il existe treize
variétés de bonbons
et plus de 600 spécialités régionales.
Des durs, des collants,
des mous comme celui-ci
ou celui-là, vous savez,
les bonbons qui collent aux dents.
Ce qui leur donne
cette consistance particulière ?
C'est la gélatine qu'il y a à l'intérieur.
Alors, pendant longtemps,
les confiseurs ont utilisé du collagène.
Il s'agit d'une protéine extraite
de la peau animale, du porc
ou du bœuf. Après l'avoir fait bouillir
pendant des heures,
ce collagène est transformé en gélatine,
puis il est ajouté
au mélange et c'est lui
qui donne de l'élasticité aux bonbons.
Bon, je sais, ça donne moins envie.
Heureusement, de plus en plus de marques
se passent de cette gélatine et utilisent
désormais de l'amidon ou des algues
pour donner cette texture à leurs bonbons.
Moi, j'adore les bonbons à la fraise.
Et là, c'est très étonnant.
Pour fabriquer un bonbon rouge,
par exemple, il n'utilise pas des fraises
mais du jus de betterave.
Pour un bonbon vert
du jus d'épinard, pour un bonbon jaune
du curcuma, un bonbon orange du paprika.
Il a pourtant pas un goût
de betterave ce bonbon.
Il faut en effet distinguer le colorant
et les arômes. Pour obtenir
le goût souhaité,
les confiseurs utilisent souvent
des arômes artificiels, c'est
à dire des produits de synthèse
qui reconstituent chimiquement
les molécules aromatiques du fruit
fraise, orange, pêche, framboise.
Mais pourquoi aime-t-on autant les bonbons ?
C'est dans la tête que ça se passe.
Ils agissent sur notre cerveau
quand on les croque.
Les glucides qu'ils contiennent provoquent
la libération de dopamine,
qu'on appelle aussi l'hormone du plaisir.
Le même phénomène se produit d'ailleurs
quand on consomme des produits gras. Pourquoi?
Eh bien parce que ces produits contiennent
beaucoup de calories, autrement
dit l'énergie dont a besoin
notre organisme.
La libération de cette hormone
du plaisir a incité
nos ancêtres à se nourrir par plaisir.
Alors aujourd'hui, on n'en est plus là.
Et même si les bonbons, c'est bon,
eh bien il faut y aller mollo.
Car justement, ils sont très riches
en glucides et que les glucides
qui ne sont pas utilisés
par notre organisme sont stockés
sous forme de graisse.
Donc, les bonbons c'est
un de temps en temps
et comme le dit la formule
pour votre santé,
évitez de manger trop gras,
trop sucré, trop salé.
Tiens, d'ailleurs, quel parfum
préférez-vous ? Allez,
Dites-le-moi en commentaire.
Et si vous avez aimé cette vidéo,
n'hésitez pas à vous abonner pour être sûr
de ne pas passer à côté des bonnes choses.